[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
chaos in the courtroom as the judge
makes a decision in the murder trial of
an olympic gymnast brother
prosecutors of the so-called doomsday
mom fired back calling requests made by
the defense absurd
the latest on laurie vallo day bell
after she's ruled incompetent to stand
trial
should derek chovan's request for a new
trial be denied what you need to know
before the ex-cop is sentenced for the
murder of george floyd
plus the infamous cadaver note revealed
to jurors in the robert durst trial
could the letter hold clues as the real
estate heir stands charged in the death
of his best friend
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
we begin with the tense moments in a
courtroom in cleveland
after a judge throws out the murder case
against the brother of olympic gymnast
simone biles
angina libya is here with a body cam
video that was recording in the
courtroom
brian tevin biles thomas faced a long
list of charges related to the deaths of
three people but the case
ended in dramatic fashion when the judge
granted
biles thomas's request for an acquittal
the sheriff's deputy's body camera had
just been activated so you can't hear
the sound
but you can clearly see a man stand up
as a woman sitting in a
chair drops her head in disappointment
then
the mother of one of the three people
who died in the new year's eve 2018
shooting rushed the defense table
yelling i'm going to kill you
at biles thomas sheriff's deputies
stopped her
get back get back this was the second
trial for bios thomas his first ended in
a mistrial last month
after the jury reported receiving
documents during the deliberations that
discussed biles thomas's possible
defense
this second trial ended with the judge
granting the defense request for a
judgment of acquittal
and tears
all right let's clear the courtroom
let's clear the courtroom biles thomas
and his famous sister simone biles were
raised by different family members
in 2019 simone biles tweeted asking for
privacy
and saying her heart ached for all
involved especially the victims and
their families
she is on her way to the olympics and
now her brother is a free man
over the objections of the victims
families
you're a hoe man
and the woman who ran toward miles
thomas was not charged the judge did not
hold a hearing to see whether or not she
would be held in contempt or not
brian thanks again now joining us today
is presidential partner attorney tammy
allison and co-host terry austin
teddy what's your reaction to the judge
not holding anyone in contempt for that
outburst
hi brian and terry thank you for having
me i believe that the judge
understands that in these types of
emotional situations
where there is a victim that is deceased
that there could be emotional outbursts
as we've seen here
i do think that the judge's decision not
to hold her in contempt was appropriate
given the fact that she had just heard
that news
and was hoping that there was would not
be an acquittal so that there could be
um justice for the victim and the
victim's family
terry what do you think did the judge
make the right call here in terms of
evaluating
everyone's emotions as tammy's is
talking about
oh i definitely think the judge read the
room well
and made sure that she didn't hold
anyone in contempt because it's a
difficult
judgment to listen to when in fact one
of your relatives has been
killed whether or not the judge made the
right decision is difficult to say
this was a full acquittal it wasn't a
dismissal without prejudice and
the one thing the judge said was that
she was
looking at the evidence and the light
most favorable to the state but she said
that
it was 75 accurate which i don't think
she should have said she should have
just simply said
that the evidence was insufficient to
sustain
a conviction and left it at that i think
it was that piece of
information that upset the woman in the
courtroom the relative
yeah the judge did take a point to say
about the identification procedures and
how
whether or not it was 75 accurate that
this was the defendant who committed
this crime or not
and have you ever seen a judge grant a
request from a judgment of acquittal
you know brian i've covered a lot of
trials over the last 16 years or so and
i've never seen a judge grant one of
these
it almost seems like a formality most of
the times that the defense attorney does
this because that's their job
and they have to say that the state
didn't prove its case but
you've seen judges maybe at a bench
trial find a defendant
not guilty and you've seen juries find a
defendant not guilty
but i've never seen one of these granted
makes sense now we'll continue thank you
everyone
now to colorado where jury selection is
continuing for a fourth day in the trial
of a father accused of murdering his son
thirteen-year-old dylan redwine vanished
over thanksgiving weekend in 2012.
in 2017 a grand jury indicted mark
redwine for second-degree murder and
child abuse resulting in death
according to court documents dylan
reportedly found compromising photos of
his father
including him wearing women's clothing
and eating feces from a diaper he was
wearing
potential drugs are now being
individually questioned about their
possible knowledge of the case
opening statements are scheduled for
monday afternoon be sure to tune in to
law and crime network for galvil gavel
coverage
and in georgia a father convicted in his
son's hot car death has been denied a
new trial
host of the law and crime show prime
crime jesse weber explains
hey there brian it's the justin ross
harris case this is the father who
killed his toddler's son
by leaving him in a hot car the question
is was this an
accident or murder to help us figure
that out we go to one of the most
revealing and unpredictable police
interviews
we've ever covered on the show i pulled
in i pulled him out
and you know i for a few minutes
i guess forward to play eternity but for
just a few seconds i attended cpr
and i i i couldn't compose myself to do
it
and that's just part of the story
there's a lot more to this georgia
father
than meets the eye tune in to law and
crime
thanks jesse be sure to check out prime
crime with our very own jesse webber
still ahead on law and crime daily
strong words from the prosecutors
of the doomsday cult mom now deemed
incompetent to stand trial
but first the murder trial of robert
durst continues the evidence in the
death of his best friend
you don't want to miss
welcome back one of the first detectives
to investigate susan berman's death
takes the stand in the robert durst
trial and testifies about the infamous
note
sent to police about a cadaver susan
berman was gunned down at her home in
california in december 2000.
investigators say there was no evidence
of forced entry 15 years later
her best friend robert durst was
arrested for her murder
prosecutors say durst shot berman
because she threatened to go public with
information
about durst's missing wife kathy on the
same day as berman's death
a letter was sent to the beverly hills
police department with the word
cadaver detective from beverly hills pd
that told me that he had learned about
the murder of
susan berman and that he had received
a letter with a note inside
there was an envelope with a note inside
of it okay
you thought was going to be of interest
to me is that a photograph
of the letter that was inside the
envelope before it was sent out for
processing forensic processing yes it is
and is that the envelope that you
received from beverly hills police
department
yes it is and i assume it did not appear
like
this in terms of the coloration
discoloration
and the other residue from forensic
testing at the point in time you
received it is that fair that was great
and they were sent out for dna analysis
yes it was
were you able to get any dna off the
envelope no or the letter
no on cross the defense asked the
detective about possible contamination
at the crime scene
including when two people broke into
berman's home
found that out yes okay and there were
actually two people
who were able to get into this secured
house isn't that true
yes it is okay did you leave the windows
unlocked
no i don't believe i did okay do you
know did you observe any other officers
leaving the windows online
no okay and of course between the first
visit the second visit and the third
visit
people besides law enforcement were
going into the house
correct that happened yes okay
and that really jeopardizes
the security of the scene for purposes
of evidence collection doesn't it
it can do you recall that the interior
door
in the room where miss berman was found
had chips on the floor by the door jam
yes okay did you dust that area for
fingerprints
i don't recall okay did you check that
area for hair fibers
i don't recall did you do anything to
secure that area with respect to dna
no on redirect prosecutors asked
if it was unusual for no forensic
evidence to be collected
inside the home that may have linked
durs to berman's murder
i want you to assume that the defendant
was in the home saw the body picked up
things off the desk wrote a note all
inside that home
and actually was inside that home
notwithstanding that fact assuming
that's true
are you saying there was still no
forensic evidence saying he was there
that was obtained okay and is that out
of the ordinary for you that
someone might admittedly be inside a
home but not leave a trace
is that out of the ordinary no thank you
all right additional cross-examination
but you really didn't take everything
did you
excuse me you didn't really take
everything to have it tested did you
you left the newspaper correct there was
things left yes
okay you left the envelopes that were on
her desk correct
i did not have any clue what i was
searching for at the time i
had a person who was executed laying on
the floor
what's interesting about this as the
defense attorney and prosecutors are
talking about what is
is or is not unusual in an investigation
you have
a prosecutor john lewin changing the
urine bag
of robert durst to make sure this trial
goes ahead
it's going forward no matter what just
wanted to throw that in but terry let's
dive into some of this testimony
detective roberts was the lead detective
on the case was this an important
witness for the prosecution
i think he was a solid witness brian i
don't think he was
perfect obviously there were some
discrepancies as far as
the investigation was concerned but he
was the first one
on the scene he was the lead detective
he did a thorough search he
established the fact that the premises
had not been broken
into nothing looked like it was
disheveled
or that anyone had robbed the place so i
think he did
establish those things for the
prosecution
and he did say that he sent many of the
pieces of evidence
to the lab for testing and that he
didn't get anything back on for instance
the shell casing
so he was solid he wasn't perfect but he
did a good job
he did all of those things well but the
defense uh poked a lot of holes in an
investigation about contamination and
people breaking in
but was that enough to cause reasonable
doubt in this case
i believe it it could have been enough i
mean the fact that
he questioned him and questioned the
fact that he did not take fingerprints
he didn't take the envelopes off of her
desk
there are so many things that he could
have done that he did not do
and we have to remember here that there
really is no evidence tying mr durst to
the murder of susan berman
all we have is circumstantial evidence
and motive and the motive is
circumstantial at best
as well so i do believe that the defense
did a really good job of poking holes
into um the prosecution's case to create
doubt and we all know that the burden of
proof is beyond a reasonable doubt
it's gonna be a very interesting
summation when they put all of these
pieces
after weeks and months of testimony
together to see how it all kind of ties
in it's going to be something to watch
make sure to check it out law and
crime's got you covered for gavin to
gavel cover there
coming up on law and crime daily should
derrick showman be granted a new trial
for the murder of george floyd
plus the request made by attorneys for
laurie valodevo
as she has moved to a mental health
facility white prosecutors are calling
them
inappropriate next
welcome back prosecutors of the
so-called doomsday mom are calling a
list of demands
made by attorneys for laurie valodebel
absurd
terry austin has been closely following
the case and is here to explain the
latest update in the doomsday
cult couple saga brian this is all
because lori valodebel was deemed
incompetent to stand trial
just weeks ago lori valo daybell
along with her husband chad dabell are
facing murder charges
in connection with the deaths of her two
children jj valo
and tyler ryan and the death of chad's
first wife tammy
chad is pleading not guilty while lori's
case is on hold
for now according to east idaho news
means is claiming in court documents
that laurie valo day bell is in a
fragile mental state of incompetency
as a direct result of the historical and
systemic
mental emotional and physical abuse she
suffered
means is requesting to be directly
involved in her treatment
and for the names and credentials of all
people involved in her care
and the medication and proposed plans
but
now prosecutor rob wood is firing back
in court documents
woods says he informed means about a
call he made
with the idaho department of health
director about lori's treatment
he's asking the judge to deny the
defense's motion
calling the request unfounded and
legally unauthorized
terry what is adamantly objecting to
mark means request to control laurie's
medical treatment
why do you think that is you know what i
find
interesting is that wood did not object
to the fact that lori was deemed
incompetent
but now he is objecting to the fact that
mark means is overreaching and i think
that that is a good move mark means
is overreaching here and i think that
wood is upset
not only because means is asking for
information he's not entitled to
but he also accused wood of wrongdoing
and it's not the first time
that wood has been accused of wrongdoing
and i think he's getting tired of it
means he's claiming that would withheld
certain information
and that's just not the fact at least
according to wood so
i think that in fact wood is just tired
of seeing
all of the shenanigans on behalf of lori
valodebel
and he's finally putting his foot down
and asking the judge
to do the same all right sorry long list
of demands but what's the likelihood
that the judge
uh grants this unusual request by mark
means
you know i think the judge is not going
to make the request
unless we get a health care proxy i mean
the judge has to be careful here he has
to make sure
that lori valede bell herself is making
this
request of her attorney and not just the
attorney doing this
on his own so i think that if we get the
proxy
it will be a decision that the judge can
make but without it he can't do it
interesting turn of events we'll see how
that plays out thank you terry when we
come back
breaking down legal arguments as derrick
sherman prepares to be sentenced
the state now asking a judge to deny his
request for a new trial
and more
welcome back ahead of derrick sheldon's
sentencing next week
prosecutors are asking that the defense
motion for a new trial
be denied angel olivia is back with more
of what prosecutors are saying in
newly filed yeah brian the state is
arguing
very strongly against derrick shoven
being granted a new trial
and they say that no misconduct occurred
during the trial
we the jury in the above entitled matter
as to count one
unintentional second-degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
derek shovin was found guilty of three
charges earlier this year for the murder
of george floyd
the ex-cop wants his convictions thrown
out saying he didn't get a fair trial
but prosecutors disagree and in court
documents note that the defense did not
use all of its preemptory challenges
or strikes for jurors without cause
and the state says public accounts by
juror number 52
brandon mitchell demonstrates the jury
carefully followed the court's
instructions and did not consume
news law and crime spoke with mitchell
after the verdict
once you're in the courtroom and you're
there and and you're a human being
you're watching somebody die
on a day-to-day basis the stress and the
emotional draining
and the mental mental drainage that that
causes
um you don't even think about anything
going on outside of there
you're now engulfed in and watching
these videos and hearing this agony and
this pain
but chauvin's defense says mitchell
didn't disclose that he participated in
a march on washington
and is requesting a hearing a photo
surfaced of mitchell wearing a black
lives
matter hat and a t-shirt last summer
marked get your knee off our necks
prosecutors say there's no evidence to
suggest that
impacted the jury's thought process i
don't know
black lives matter as an organization
okay
that's i don't i don't know it as an
organization so maybe that's
i mean i don't know if that's how the
question said i don't know if it said
black lives matter organization i don't
i don't view it as that so i don't
that's not how i subscribe to that the
state also denies any misconduct alleged
by the defense for statements like this
because you're afraid that he would come
too with no pulse and rampage the city
that's the sort of thing you see in
halloween movies ladies and gentlemen
not in real life
know derek shovin faces up to 40 years
in prison when he is sentenced in court
documents prosecutors have actually
asked for a sentence of
30 years while shoving's defense has
asked for
probation and time served brian
thanks internet tammy showman's defense
team wants a mistrial
claiming one of the jurors did not
disclose that he attended this march as
we discussed
do you think that's enough for a
mistrial though
absolutely not i don't think it's enough
for a mistrial
i think that the defense is playing
coulda woulda shoulda
they should have caught that prior too
and moved to strike that juror
if that they would have diligently done
what he was supposed to do
in order to strike the juror at this
point
we have the conviction on all three
count
and next week on june 25th chauvin is up
for sentencing before this judge
who has clearly stated that he would be
considering an upward departure as well
so i think right now the defense is
doing
everything they can do to avoid having
to go to sentencing in this matter
could have would have should have is
probably the best way to say it there
terry the prosecutors argue that the
defense did not use up
all of their preemptory challenges does
that argument succeed here
i don't think it succeeds here i do
think that
there is no question this juror withheld
certain information but the real
issue is did that information
cause a change in the deliberation so
it's really not the fact
that the challenges weren't used i mean
it's a good point but i don't think
that's the point
that will enable the prosecution to
succeed i think the point
that the prosecution is going to prevail
on is
even if this juror did wear that t-shirt
went to the march had these beliefs
none of that affected the deliberation
so i think at the end of the day
we're really going to see that this
verdict is going to hold up as tammy
said i mean he was convicted on all
counts
and i definitely think that we're going
to see the sentencing and the upward
departure
on june 25th absolutely and of course
what questions were asked i think it's
an issue as to
did the defense attorney ask the proper
questions to elicit the proper answers
not sure but tammy terry thank you very
much and thank you for joining us here
at long crime daily we'll see you next
time as discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you